all right guys happy thursday we're
looking out over beautiful
snow-covered mountains like powdered
sugar out there
it is gorgeous we've got a lot of cloud
cover and it's all coming from that next
winter storm
pounding california there is rain and
snow all up and down the west coast
temperatures a little cool we're in the
30s and freezing
just above freezing in reno getting a
little bit of snow from that system
otherwise 50s along the coast this one's
a little bit milder
tapping into some milder pacific air out
there in the ocean let's talk about cold
air look at these
teens even single digits in the midwest
rain and snow
moving off the east coast wow they're
down around
freezing right there in the mid-atlantic
states and on the beachfront property
check out ocean city maryland they've
had some snow
this is the beach right here but that's
snow all that white stuff on the table
tops here
i understand from chrissy our producer
that there's a great little beach bar
right there
looks like it's called coconuts it is
kind of crazy there today isn't it
let's get back over to the west they're
going to stay in the 30s for highs there
in that part of the country for the next
several days for us we're looking at
this
winter storm just beating up california
with heavy rain
mudslides are already a problem uh
causing damage there
and they're measuring the snow in the
sierras in feet forecasting
eight to ten feet of snow from this
system
now we're sitting in the clouds but by
tonight we expect that system to start
moving inland and bring us a chance for
rain and mountain snow
54 today partly sunny overnight while
most of us are sleeping
we'll see that developing chance of some
showers cool
that we'll be in the upper 30s to near
40 by tomorrow morning and then we get
that chance of rain off and on
all through tomorrow so make sure you
got that umbrella a jacket
give yourself extra time to get where
you need to go that system should be
gone friday night
mostly sunny skies nice for the weekend
and we might get a couple of days in the
60s next week before another storm out
of the pacific northwest
brings us a chance of showers again
midweek